And let's say, I mean, there's many different solutions, but
I'd say the best answer is, minus 1 for
the x because we go left and still plus 1 for y.
These are two what's called orthogonal vectors.
Those define the two principle directions here.
In reality, when we write vectors in PCA,
what you find is lowest output vectors is normalized to one.
This one here has a length of square root of 2.
So when you, when you rescale those vectors,
you find that square root of 2 over here minus square root of 2.
And square of 2 vectors of that length have a total length of 1,
because the total length is given by the square root of the squares of the sum.
Being as it is; the principal vectors found by PCA are the one over here,
and the one over here.
So let's do this again.